Ein Bereich, in dem Quantencomputing maschinelles Lernen verbessern könnte,
hängt mit Kernel-Funktionen oder
Kernel-Matrizen zusammen – schauen wir uns an, was das ist.
Dazu erinnern wir uns an
drei Dinge: Warum tauchen Skalarprodukte im maschinellen Lernen auf?
Warum haben Probleme des maschinellen Lernens mit höheren Dimensionen zu tun?
Und was sind Kernel-Funktionen?
Zur Erinnerung: Das Skalarprodukt oder innere Produkt von
reellen n-dimensionalen Vektoren a
und b ergibt sich aus dem Produkt des Betrags von a,
dem Betrag von b und dem Kosinus des Winkels theta
zwischen ihnen. Das ist gleichwertig damit, jede Komponente von a
mit der entsprechenden Komponente von
b zu multiplizieren und zu summieren. Sind die Vektoren
nahezu orthogonal – etwa wenn a
dort null ist, wo b große Werte hat –,
ist das Skalarprodukt klein. Das entspricht
einem theta nahe pi/2.
Hat a negative Komponenten, wo b
positive Komponenten hat,
zeigen die Vektoren also in
nahezu entgegengesetzte Richtungen,
und theta ist nahe pi –
dann kann das Skalarprodukt
negativ sein. Haben a und b schließlich große Komponenten am gleichen Ort und
mit demselben Vorzeichen,
sind die Vektoren also nahezu parallel und theta nahe null –
ist das Skalarprodukt groß
und positiv. Es ist also sehr naheliegend, dass Skalarprodukte
ein nützliches Ähnlichkeitsmaß
für Datenpunkte sind. Nicht alle n-dimensionalen Daten
lassen sich leicht in einem (n-1)-dimensionalen
Schnitt trennen – also durch eine Linie,
Ebene oder Hyperebene. Wenn die Daten in n Dimensionen nicht gut trennbar sind,
können wir die Datenpunkte in
höhere Dimensionen einbetten – sagen wir m Dimensionen, wobei m
größer als n ist. Das nennt sich Feature-Mapping,
oft dargestellt als x → φ(x), wobei
φ(x) eine Abbildung von n-dimensionalen reellen Zahlen auf
m-dimensionale reelle Zahlen ist.
Am einfachsten lässt sich das vorstellen,
wenn man eine Menge eindimensionaler Daten in
zwei Dimensionen biegt oder zweidimensionale Daten
in drei Dimensionen einbettet.
In der Praxis betten wir Daten aber oft in Räume mit Tausenden
oder sogar Millionen von Dimensionen ein.
Ein Skalarprodukt dreidimensionaler Vektoren im Vergleich zu einem Skalarprodukt
zweidimensionaler Vektoren macht kaum einen Unterschied.
Ein Skalarprodukt von Vektoren mit einer Million Dimensionen
ist jedoch völlig unhandhabbar,
wenn man es auf einen großen Datensatz anwenden will.
Also haben sich die Leute einen cleveren Trick ausgedacht:
Was wäre, wenn man eine Projektion
in höhere Dimensionen verwendete, die eine ganz bestimmte Form hat –
so dass die Skalarprodukte der Vektoren in
höheren Dimensionen eine einfache Funktion der
niederdimensionalen Vektoren sind? Das heißt, wir suchen ein Mapping
von unseren Daten x in das höherdimensionale φ(x),
so dass das innere Produkt im
Feature-Raum durch eine
einfache Funktion in den niederdimensionalen Daten gegeben ist.
Diese Funktion k nennt sich Kernel-Funktion.
Idealerweise soll diese Kernel-Funktion
eine Funktion des niederdimensionalen
inneren Produkts selbst sein – das würde uns das
Beste aus beiden Welten geben: einen sehr hochdimensionalen Feature-Raum,
aber mit einem billigen und leicht berechenbaren inneren Produkt.
Auf den ersten Blick ist
nicht offensichtlich, dass das überhaupt möglich ist. Schauen wir uns
ein einfaches Beispiel in sehr niedrigen Dimensionen an.
Betrachte dieses spezifische Feature-Mapping: Es bildet einen
dreidimensionalen Vektor auf einen
neundimensionalen Raum ab. Es stellt sich heraus,
dass das innere Produkt im neundimensionalen Feature-Raum
einfach dem quadrierten inneren Produkt im ursprünglichen
dreidimensionalen Raum entspricht. Das innere Produkt
des abgebildeten Raums mit den φ-Funktionen
würde die Berechnung aller
neun Koordinaten des
ersten Vektors und neun des
zweiten erfordern, dann das innere Produkt selbst –
weitere neun Produkte und eine Summe.
Das sind insgesamt achtundzwanzig Operationen.
Die Kernel-Funktion braucht drei Produkte
und zwei Summen – also nur vier Operationen.
Das war für das Mapping eines dreidimensionalen Datenpunkts in
einen neundimensionalen Feature-Raum.
Man sieht leicht, wie vorteilhaft das
für sehr große Räume sein kann.
Die Kernel-Funktion ist typischerweise eine stetige Funktion,
die du auf jeden Vektor in deinem Datensatz anwenden kannst.
Kernel-Funktionen nutzt man, indem man
Paare von Datenpunkten aus dem Datensatz
als Argumente nimmt. Eine Kernel-Funktion auf
jedes Paar von Datenpunkten im Datensatz anzuwenden
ergibt eine symmetrische Matrix – die sogenannte Kernel-
Matrix. Welche Kernel-Funktion du verwendest, hängt von
deinem Problem ab. Kurz zusammengefasst:
Die Ähnlichkeit von Vektoren in unseren Datensätzen zu beschreiben
erfordert oft innere Produkte – innere Produkte in
sehr hochdimensionalen Feature-Räumen werden teuer.
Deshalb nutzen wir Feature-Mappings, die
bestimmten speziellen Kernel-Funktionen entsprechen
und die Berechnung effizienter machen.
Aber diese Einschränkung auf spezielle Kernel-Funktionen
schränkt auch ein, welche Arten von Mappings in den Feature-Raum
effizient durchgeführt werden können.
Das kann uns daran hindern, unsere Daten gut zu trennen –
wenn es doch nur einen anderen Weg gäbe.
Hier kommt Quantencomputing ins Spiel.
Das sehr hochdimensionale Feature-Mapping, das
Kernel-Funktionen entspricht, lässt sich
auf einem Quantencomputer im Quantum Kernel Estimator durchführen.
Die Kernel-Matrix k wird berechnet,
und von dort aus kann ein klassischer Machine-Learning-Algorithmus
die Aufgabe lösen: Ein Datenpunkt x1
wird geladen und abgebildet, dann
wird ein weiterer x2 geladen
und abgebildet. Da das innere Produkt zweier Quantenzustände
mit der Messprobabilität zusammenhängt,
lässt sich das innere Produkt der beiden abgebildeten
Datenpunkte durch ausreichend viele Messungen des
resultierenden circuit schätzen. Auf diese Weise kann uns der circuit
etwas über ein inneres Produkt
in einem beliebigen hochdimensionalen Raum verraten, den der circuit modellieren kann –
ohne dass wir jemals klassisch ein inneres Produkt oder eine
Kernel-Funktion berechnen müssen. Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten,
diese Methoden anzupassen und zu verbessern.
Tatsächlich werden immer neue Methoden vorgeschlagen
und getestet. Wir hoffen, dass dieser
Überblick hilfreich war, um die
Anwendung von Quantencomputing
auf Methoden des maschinellen Lernens
– insbesondere solche mit Kernels – einzuordnen.